Welcome, everyone!
Thank you for joining me online
to celebrate the accomplishments
of the Yale graduates of 2021!
Your deans and I congratulate
you for the extraordinary work
you have completed in
your programs of study.
We salute your effort,
your diligence,
your talent, and your intellect.
We also join you in expressing
gratitude for all who have
supported you in
these endeavors:
Your families and friends,
professors,
and other members of
the Yale community.
On June 4th, when you have been
recommended by the faculty
of your school and approved by
the Corporation,
your dean will ask me
by my official act
to confer upon you your degree.
By the authority vested in me,
I shall confer upon you
your degree
when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you to all
its rights and responsibilities.
Congratulations, to the
Yale graduates of 2021!